foreign
dang it where'd the backing go
yeah
just lost one of them
backings for the dang pen
read that ah
all right it's okay I have more
oh
there we go there we are hey everybody
got that nonsense sorted huh
uh
hope everyone's doing well
that's hot
yep that's very hot
oh there we are
huh hey everybody hope you had a good
Halloween if you chose to do anything on
it and if you didn't then I hope you had
a relaxed one
um have I watched heart stop or what are
my thoughts on one of the main actors
being forced to come out is by
I have not watched it
and I'm not familiar with that situation
huh
I would need details I'm I'm assuming
that it's a matter of they wanted to
cast
accurate to the sexuality so someone who
was closeted had to come out in order to
get the part
if it's not that if it's something else
I should
check into that because that's
unsettling
anyways uh Hey everybody so if you are
new here because we have picked up more
than a few subscribers in the last
couple weeks
um I will be uh keep an eye on the chat
as best as I can the only thing that
guarantees that I will see your comment
assuming you are not also a patreon
supporter in which case you would have
had the Discord uh prior to the start of
the stream but the only thing that
guarantees I'm going to see a reply your
comment is doing it as a super chat
which will also get you a heart from me
in appreciation so uh with that in mind
John vinyls right off the bat thank you
so much so if there was to be any
gargoyles The Owl House goes to the mall
McGee amphibia and or Gravity Falls
attractions at the Disney parks what do
you think they should be
um I would say Gravity Falls lends
itself very easily you could build an
attraction just around the town whether
it be a an attraction that you walk
through or you could set it up like it's
a very rickety roller coaster like
something uh Stan himself built and sort
of part of the appeal is like it shakes
and jutters about because it makes you
think like oh it's about to fall apart
at any moment you could build that into
it that's the one that immediately leaps
to mind gargoyles would probably be the
most difficult especially because at
this point that is a pretty Niche and
increasingly obscure property until they
do something else with it
um I wouldn't be surprised if like they
did like something minor for the ghost
of Molly McGee like within the proximity
of the Haunted Mansion that could work
Owl House is tricky too
um like honestly I'd like to just see
them
put a hoodie animatronic somewhere just
to mess with people and leave it at that
not even explain it not even have it on
an owl house thing just like on a door
like in downtown there's Hootie hello
oh well
one can dream
stupid alerts go away how was my
Halloween it was nice it was
um
it was good it like I I accompanied my
kiddo
in a very elaborate costume not me her
hey I'm not I'm not gonna share it here
because I don't share my kids image
um but like it was it was oh it was a
lot
um and she rocked it
she she made it work
uh my Halloween was having my
neighborhood
um having a blackout because a squirrel
got into the Transformer
uh I know because it's corpse was in my
driveway oh
Castile I'm so sorry
oh my goodness we went to the Mummers
Day Parade in our town one of my friends
asked if I'd ever been to a pride parade
and when I said no he offered to take me
Mummers like I don't know
um where you're located I've seen like a
members parade in like I don't think it
was in Philadelphia proper but it was
close to it there
the thing
I guess compared to a pride brain makes
some degree of sense as much senses can
be made
uh one of the main actors who's 18 came
out as bi recently due to being harassed
and accused of queerbaiting
playing a bike character and being seen
with a girl
so yeah okay so it wasn't quite what I
thought it was but it wasn't too far off
and
ah
it um
it is a
it is a difficult thing
um because this is kind of a Fallout of
the push for you know queer people to
play queer roles
but I think especially when you're
dealing with characters as young as the
characters in Heart Stopper are it
becomes more likely you're going to end
up in a situation like that and the fact
that the criticism was directed at the
actor so strongly that that happened
rather than concerns being
you know projected at say the producers
you know that the actor was just hired
to do the job
and unless they are a huge name actor
who can pick and choose their roles like
to pull a random name I don't know where
Scarlett Johansson unless you're of that
caliber the actor is not especially
responsible for the nature of their
casting
especially young actors trying to break
in they're going to audition for
anything and everything that they can
get their foot in the door on and
they'll take whatever is said yes to
generally broadly speaking
jar jar Ed hello there thank you very
much uh Dr Sam Loomis the Halloween
character that got so crazy he shot
Michael Myers seven times with a six
shot revolver hey the man was determined
Donald Pleasence did not leave a job
half done except that apparently didn't
kill him so I guess he did
oh Dr Loomis
uh what is your yearly October and
Halloween watch list
um it's basically three things
um like during the month I might watch
any number of things but like very close
to it the must watch before the
um
before the end of the month are
um Garfield's Halloween
um The Legend of Sleepy Hollow portion
of the adventures of a kabad and Mr Toad
um from Disney and The Real Ghostbusters
episode when Halloween was forever those
are the three must be watched before the
month is over items for me every year
half have to consume those
there are others that like I do
intermittently like say Over the Garden
Wall or um you know just trying to take
in some some scary movies or whatnot but
those are the big ones
did I go as rose quartz no I I just I
just threw on some uh
some witchy attire and left it at that I
I didn't have it in me to do anything
elaborate have I seen Wendolyn Wilde I
have not I would like to I have not had
time
have you ever seen the extreme
Ghostbuster show only clips
I never I never watched it properly I've
never actually seen a full episode John
vinyls once again thank you so very much
I guess you could have uh Caleb and
Phillip portraits as the Duelists in the
Haunted Mansion oh
that could work
like little nods like that would be kind
of fun for those who catch it
uh the actor in question from Heart
Stopper also played younger Elton John
in Rocket Man ah
oh so I really wonder if this was
something that was kind of trailing him
off the back of that I don't know I
don't know it uh it's messy and it makes
me uncomfortable
um
excuse me I went with friends dressed as
Batman characters naturally The Joker
was banned I was I went as Alfred
britishness intensifies
that'll do it
uh you should have gone as the macaroni
which will make no sense unless you
watch the Harley Quinn cartoon
Supreme
Omega good to have you here hello even
though red hood is popular I feel Jason
should have stayed dead his Revival
removes Batman's second tragedy and it
undermines Tim's Arc as Robin yeah I
agree
I know some people really like Jason
Todd I know some people really like him
as a character or and or really like the
the initial Red Hood uh storyline in
particular
um
I don't like it I think he should have
stayed dead and barring that if he was
going to come back I think he should
have stayed a villain or at least
um lean way more villain than he does
because at this point they've kind of
sought him in slotted him into
anti-hero and I think if he's not going
to be dead which he should be then I
think the much more interesting thing is
to
have him be the one
who knows all of Batman's tactics but is
and will always be willing to do them
more extreme than Batman does and
sometimes that makes him more effective
and that would make him a philosophical
threat to Batman to Batman's core
Notions of what he's doing if someone
like
um Jason comes in and not only like as a
one-off but on a continual basis
is doing it harsher than
anybody in the bat family does or will
ever do and is getting better results
that there's a story to be had there and
it's not one that they're telling now
he's just
he's just the most damaged Robin
yay
ah
one of the trick-or-treaters said trick
or treat bro to me
uh
how did Over the Garden Wall go over uh
we're about halfway through it so
um she still wants to see the rest of it
so we'll we'll see how that goes
um let's see where was I
I binge watched American Horror Story
Anthem and the pilot enjoyed them but
the pilot dragged uh but I thought I
blame you hopefully I can resist my OCD
and not binge the entire series
uh yeah hopefully not like I've only
seen five seasons of the thing and like
I've heard mixed things about it since
then so who knows it's not Halloween for
me unless I watch 1963 version of The
Haunting that's a solid pick that work
as long as it's not the 99 version
NGP thank you so very much for the
support I haven't managed to catch your
stream in ages happy post Halloween
thank you Angie happy post Halloween to
you too
uh
and all that jazz labeling Dom or an
lgbtq Plus show during all this
anti-lgbtq plus crap at the moment
uh I have avoided Dahmer as a show and
as a talking point
because
like I've I've honestly never been super
comfortable with
um
you know just uh
real life
horror like that being milked for
entertainment like there's a value in
real life stories
um there is but I do think that real
life serial killer stories lend
themselves to some of the grossest
exploitation that real life stories as
entertainment tends to take
um he also played Carolyn Ford's
character's grandson in an adventure in
space and time that's not relevant to
the situation but any excuse to bring up
an adventure in space and time that is
that is a good movie
Halloween is the only communal holiday
holidays like Eastern Christmas can be
communal but Halloween is the only one
that requires it interest
Alyssa
yeah
yeah uh because those ones can be
self-contained and can be just familial
assuming one
um celebrates them but yeah no Halloween
by its nature
involves other people yeah very cool
um
Jacob I did already review it in the
break room you need to go and check that
went up last week
I watched the new trailer for
disenchanted earlier today I saw it was
out I haven't watched it yet I got
today was a shooting day so I've been
mostly camped out over there in front of
the camera it's also it's also why I'm
so pretty
because I wanted to look all nice and
crap
ah
Dharma remember for 12 months thank you
so much for that 12 months as a rabble
Rouser and no regrets all hail the
council and she who runs the meetings
thank you Dharma I appreciate that
whether you're trick-or-treating taking
a family member trick-or-treating
handing out candy to trick-or-treaters
or just going out partying you are
participating in the community yeah like
if if you're not in some way involved in
a community activity then you're kind of
not really doing Halloween
you're kind of ducking out on the whole
thing
like with some people like that's not uh
that's not too um slam the door on the
possibility of like introverted people
using it as an excuse to put a certain
aesthetic around the house and just
watch scary movies on their own like
that's valid but
um
certainly the core
um practices of the holiday those are
communal
have I seen the movie Cannibal Holocaust
Human Centipede or Martyrs uh could you
ever do it I will not watch Cannibal
Holocaust I would not even accept that
as a commission if somebody tried
because it depicts real life uh animal
abuse and I won't uh Human Centipede I
have no interest have never seen Martyrs
I don't even know what that is all of
these sound likes if if it's branching
off in a similar vein as the other two I
probably would not want to watch it
oh hey John good to see you JBL in the
house
good to see you my friend do you prefer
the original Evil Dead for the gore and
slapstick or Evil Dead 2 for the more
comedic horror bent I have my fave but
I'm curious I think Evil Dead do Evil
Dead 2 is the platonic ideal of that
franchise frequently
um funny
but also able even in his funny moments
to just unnerve you out of nowhere
whether it is
um Ash's reflection suddenly jumping out
of the mirror and grabbing him or
whether it be you know the um the
various things in the room starting to
laugh and you're like it's unsettled but
it's also funny that really hit the
balance really well the original Evil
Dead uh is a bit too much
straightforward horror
um for its own good I think
um Evil Dead 2 does some intentional
comedy very very well and then from Army
of Darkness onward it's uh frankly a
little bit too self-aware
um that's part of why I didn't stick
with uh Ash versus the evil dead though
I heard decent things
ah
jar jar Ed thank you once again for the
Super Chat Jason I'm so damaged Damian
cool story bro dick where's Tim Jason
and Damian who
uh there's um
there's a tick tock
Creator I want to get his handle right
um he does just in general a lot of um
of comic book stuff
but he does some does a fair amount of
Batman stuff
um
it was the panda red
uh with uh Redd at the very end he does
so much stuff and he does a lot of skits
where he's like playing the different
robins or playing Batman he does a lot
of stuff like that it's really funny if
if that stuff appeals to you you should
check him out it's good stuff
so it was the real Rasputin locked in a
Cupboard somewhere are we supposed to
believe the master was rasputed and if
so uh was the bonium song of bootstrap
paradox
I don't know and like
the simple thing is I don't I don't care
that much I'm not enough of a pothole
sniffer to actually have much of a
weighted concern about that
uh let's see I got compliments on my
reindeer onesie and penguin slippers
whatever works I guess
so much to do so many publish us to
perform the kiddo has been getting into
ice skating best of luck with that that
can be a tricky one
what are some examples of uh creatives
who you recognize are talented but you
do not love their work uh Zack Snyder's
first one that leaps to mind
he's very talented
I don't like most of his stuff
um
see I almost said Stanley Kubrick
except that makes it seem like my issues
with Kubrick begin and end with him not
appealing to my tastes when it runs a
little bit deeper than that as to why I
really don't like his work
um my problems with him are kind of
bigger than him as an individual
um
let me think
yeah Snyder's the the main one that
leaps to mind off off the top of my head
there are there are others I'm just I'm
just kind of drawing a blank at the
moment
I mean I
the wachowskis are very hit and miss for
me they are incredibly talented
um but they do they like they get it for
me they nail it like one out of five
uh
let's see
I've started taking CBD to mount myself
out I hope that helps I hope that works
well for you
uh what else we got
a few months ago I asked whether Doctor
Who was more divisive than it used to be
I didn't just mean new who versus the
classics
like
yes but so is every fandom
that's not a doctor who problem that is
a fan culture problem
so
yes but it's not reflective of problems
with Doctor Who it's reflective of
cultural problems that are affecting
Doctor Who so
uh what things do you consume
what things what Halloween things you
consume for the first time this month
well barbarian was the big one
um in terms of
you know a flat out horror movie and I
would I would also call the um the Owl
House special as being pretty Halloweeny
those would be the two main ones
and I'll and I'll also reiterate that
even though I am willing to cop that the
that pretty much all fandoms are more
divisive than they used to be the
divisive elements are not new but they
are louder and more widespread because
being being uh significantly older than
most of my audience
I remember a time before the internet
I remember where if you were going to be
a jerk about something about a piece of
fandom you couldn't you couldn't affect
anything more than your immediate
surroundings now that could still be
messed up
I've cited this before
um but I remember in grade school where
some of the older kids picked on like
grade one grade two kids because they
liked the Ewoks cartoon
and the older kids liked the Star Wars
movies and they considered that to be
for babies so like that that
toxicity is not new it's reach is new
and because of that reach and a general
cultural shift towards
people not accepting that some things
just aren't made for them and maybe
that's okay yeah things have gotten more
divisive but I do feel it's important to
remember the divisive elements are not
new
they've always been there because then
it becomes too easy to blame
well to blame any one thing to blame the
rage merchants on a site like YouTube to
blame the far-right people who have
deliberately made an effort to integrate
themselves into various fandoms that's
not supposition that's a fact that's
documented it's very easy to blame them
and like these things don't help but
they didn't start a fire out of nothing
there were Embers that they were able to
Flame and those Embers were always there
ah
let's see where was I
have I seen bound oh I love bound
bound's great I gotta get that on DVD
that is uh that is a great movie
being someone with a particular taste in
horror what horror media do you like the
most
I'm very fond of horror aesthetic being
used to tell a not specifically Horror
Story this is part of what I really like
about Guillermo del Toro his movies are
drenched in horror aesthetic and
um
visualization and tone but the actual
stories are often not horror stories or
at least they're not straightforward
horror stories pretty much the only one
he did that was was mimic and even that
I had fun with
ah
FYI my partner's Google Assistant just
asked if we wanted to plan something for
Bram Stoker's birthday which is coming
up what kind of experience are we
planning
foreign
things like Google Assistant kind of
freaked me out a little bit
huh uh Supreme Omega thank you very much
for a another Super Chat also on bats I
wish adaptations had more casts and
Steph Cass was back girl stuff was Tim's
main love interests and also Batgirl yet
they still get sidelined it was actually
one of the minor annoyances I have with
the bird of prey movie which I actually
really like
I didn't even dislike the character of
Cassandra Kane it's just that that
character was not Cassandra Kane
like they could have called her
literally anything else and it would
have fit better
um but yeah like there's
there's a general issue with a lot of
the adaptations especially of the DC
stuff Marvel is Marvel because it's been
going for as long and as strong as it
has been is able to like pull from some
deeper Cuts uh over time but because
it's like they're constantly freaking
resetting Batman every other movie
um they keep revisiting the same things
it's like oh it's pre-robbin or like
they apply Robin's dead and you know and
we never get around to
people like Steph or like Cass or and
geez any of the
numerous other ones I actually I
[Music]
um
I I had a bit of fun with uh with Jesse
gender
excuse me uh on Twitter because she had
posted that she's playing
um Arkham Knights
is that what it is Batman Arkham Knights
whatever the new Batman Arkham game is
the one that's supposed to be terrible
um she's been playing that and like she
had tweeted out who should I play as and
I had fun basically listing every uh
non-white or non-heterosexual
um character that I knew wasn't playable
in the game I was like oh plays the
signal oh wait plays batwing oh wait
plays Cassandra Kane oh wait play as
Batwoman oh wait
so I gotta had some fun with that
uh do you know of the new CW show Gotham
nights about Bruce's adopted son none
other Robbins by the way teeny meeting
up with villains children to prove their
innocence for the murder of his dad
I feel like I heard it was in
development has it actually happening
for real for real are we sure about that
um
yeah
let's see
chh
where was I there we go uh shot in the
dark have you seen
dhmis
I don't know what I bring this up uh
every now and then
um Black cover I I I don't I'm really
bad at acronyms if it's not like a
really well-known one I I don't I don't
know what dhmis is so I have no idea
it's it's really bad to try and talk to
me with acronyms it doesn't work very
well
I still maintain the Norms have ruined
the internet the internet ruined itself
that's that is my position
uh
what about Crimson Peak that was him
right that was him but that's a that is
more of a tragic love story than it is a
horror story
I love bound when I was a teenager I now
love it for diff uh additional reasons
do I eat Halloween candy not really I
don't do handouts from my house so I
don't generally end up with any John
vinyls once again thank you so very much
am I the only one who thinks the Owl
House took more than a little influence
from Clive Barker
um
I'm not familiar with enough of his
stuff to make a call
but I could see it
it it doesn't sound like utter nonsense
so I'll give you that Thomas Scott thank
you very much for the Super Chat have
you seen Cabinet of Curiosities also
have you seen Capaldi's new show the
devil's hour he pretty much said similar
to Eccleston he won't return
I have not gotten to Covenant of
Curiosities I haven't had the time I
tried uh watching the first episode of
The Devil's hour and got bored basically
I was there for Capaldi and they
withheld him for too long and my brain
wandered off
um and yes it is a shame that he's
saying he won't return
um I'm not necessarily going to say I
hope he changes his mind
I would love more capali stories I'll
hold out for more Hope from possibly
being big finish than uh actually
appearing again on the show who knows
though who knows just wanted to shout
out the comics uh camp counselor Jason
and Irma they're a comedic series that
depict Jason as head of Crystal Lake and
the girl from The Ring has a mom
that works I can see that especially if
you know like some of the Ring media
some some of the media around the ring
is linkara has done a number of things
about some of the lesser-known uh
aspects of that franchise and did their
their bonkers
uh
thoughts on any of Stephen King's works
I just finished Pat Cemetery video in
the near future pluggedy plug
um
sorry I've got some of my lip stain
coming off on this mug
I've mentioned before that I've actually
never finished
a Stephen King book I started reading I
think it was the Gunslinger like his
writing style just doesn't
flow for me and it's not bad I don't
think he's a bad writer it just doesn't
it just doesn't connect
I find his ideas interesting enough that
I'm certainly not opposed to seeing
movies based off some of his stuff if
they look like they're good Melody Queen
thank you very much for the super chat
if you had one question to ask chibnol
what would it be
what do you think chibnol would want it
to be
I think jingle would want what I think
most creatives want to be asked what are
you most proud of
um what would I actually ask him
uh This is Gonna kind of tip my hand to
what tomorrow's video is going to be to
a certain extent but I would ask him was
that really it
in regards to the Timeless child
was that really all you had was there
really nothing more that you intended to
do with that idea
so
Nancy Gross thank you so much for the
Super Chat just dropped in to give you a
belated Halloween treat I love treats uh
keep up the awesome work oh honestly I
think I just finally found the
the pin backing
uh I think it's on the floor now
uh
means don't hug me I'm scared ah I am
familiar with that I've heard of it I
have never watched it it it didn't it
never like struck me as my vibe it was a
it was one of those things I found it
interesting to watch
people talk about
but I never really had much interest in
engaging with it directly
have I read any agrellum Poe's books
yeah a couple couple I actually rather
like uh murderer uh on the Rue Morgue
the the
um
the answer to the mystery is kind of
batch it but it's it's a it's a pretty
good book
don't hug me I scan I'm scared it's like
a TV show proper now
oh geez
that's odd that strikes me as very odd
uh do you think you'll ever let Liz
explain more Riverdale to you uh so very
not the Archies that grow up on the
Archies cartoon
um so yes and no we shot a bunch of
stuff
um when she was reciting the river Veil
plot line to me
um and there's
so I had two videos up I took one of
them down because I accidentally like
part of it looped back on itself and
repeated
um I fixed that the the fixed version
goes up later this month and I'm gonna
have one more video though that'll get
out of the stuff that's already shot
um no current plans to record any
additional stuff along those lines
but there will be a total of three
videos uh in that weird little sub
series of Liz breaking my brain
by recounting the plot of Riverdale
hmm
dad joke Cinema first of all I love the
name thank you so much for the Super
Chat my kids have been having a big
debate about which doctor intro was
their favorite my six-year-old has an
issue with ones that showed the doctor's
face she thinks they're creepy what's
your fave I for the most part for the
most part there are a couple of
exceptions but generally uh I agree with
your six-year-old I don't like the
doctor's face in the opening credit
cards it doesn't help that more often
than not they picked a unpleasant or
unsettling image
like especially the ones they have for
Tom Baker especially that last one they
have for Tom Baker where his head was
like slightly tilted back he's like
[Applause]
but like they can't seem to get good
shots at all
um one of my favorites and it actually
might have been my favorite at the time
was actually
the John the last John pertwe one where
it was the only one where instead of
just the face they did full body like it
started on his face but then it zoomed
down it's the full body
I thought that worked I thought that
worked a heck of a lot better than just
the head the disembodied head thing I've
never really liked and the Doctor Who
credits
uh whenever they've done it
do I think Jody Whitaker will go on to
make big finish audios uh if so what are
your hopes well I can guarantee you big
big finish will want her to whether or
not she says yes is the question because
not all of them do Eccleston has
um they got you know some from John Hurt
before he passed tenant has Matt Smith
has not as yet Capaldi says he doesn't
intend to
um Joe Martin has said yes big finish
will certainly ask and unless she flat
out tells them no never
um they will probably ask at
intermittent intervals if they think
there's any possibility and it doesn't
come across as pestering her so as
opposed to what my hopes would be
I mean on the one hand they could try
and tie up the mess that is all the
dangling plot lines but honestly I'd
rather see them do their own thing that
having been said big finish has a pretty
decent track record of spinning gold out
of plot holes
um and missing pieces so honestly I'd
just do what they do because they're
good at it
may I recommend that if you ever decide
to pick
uh pick side King up again
uh
oh it picked Stephen King up again you
pick 11 22 63 it's one of my favorite
novels ever written I don't have plans
to pick him up again but I'll
huh
I I would say uh I'll keep it in mind
but realistically if and when I ever
think to
um
get around to trying Stephen King again
I won't remember because I have I have a
sieve for a brain
so
there we go
um let's see whoo lots of super chats in
today all right I've been trying to keep
up with the chat in general I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to just catch up on the
super chats right now and then just jump
to the bottom of the of the uh chat
after that I think so jar jar Ed thank
you again after seeing Halloween ends I
can safely say I prefer watching
original Halloween Halloween 2 and H2O
over the recent the whole victims being
defined by one horrible night is
overdone and boring I am
inclined to agree
now I haven't actually seen any of the
new Trilogy I actually haven't seen any
of the Halloween movies
in their entirety start to finish at all
but I did see
um I think it was Jeremy John's video uh
he did recently on Halloween H2O and
saying that that is his preferred
Halloween Trilogy Halloween Halloween 2
and then H2O
Thomas Scott once again thank you so
much uh Devil's our exec is Stephen
Moffett tenant uh also just did a show
written by Mafia called Inside Man with
Stanley 2G I'm so excited for new who
like I'm glad that everybody's staying
busy and it's nice that these that these
folks still work together
um you know on other stuff
uh how do I go about writing a Horror
Story
I've only written
I've only written I think a couple of
short stories that I would say are
intended as horror stories
uh that having been said there are parts
of my book that like seem to fairly
reliably unnerved people one part much
more so than I was expecting to but I'm
like cool I dig it
um but
I think I approach horror the same way I
take it in which is that like something
that's aiming to just scare me I'm like
I I I'm not really going to engage
something that is aiming to tell me a
good story that also along the way
scares or unsettles or horrifies me that
is much more likely to get my attention
and so the times that I've written
horror stories I was I didn't sit down
and go I'm gonna write a horror story
now I did in both in case of both those
short stories uh which are not available
anywhere so don't don't bother looking
um I did sit down
and think I want to do a story about
this
sort of thing that is a typical Horror
Story thing
like I well I basically I basically I
have a I have my spin on a werewolf
story I have my spin on a vampire story
I would say the werewolf story is more
overtly horrific than the vampire one is
but like those are both Staples of
horror although you can do things other
than horror with them but those were
worlds I wanted to play in and I decided
as I was writing if I would actually try
and do horror stuff with them or if I
would try and do
um
you know something else and I said I was
just going to skip down and focus on the
super chats and I already failed okay
Supreme Omega Nightwing I don't mind
Bruce being a bachelor but it but it
would have been cool if dick got married
to his love interest Starfire there's so
much potential they have a thing about
like what
honestly superhero comics DC especially
has this
massive aversion
massive stunning aversion to heroes in
stable relationships Marvel has it a bit
but DC has it bad and it's one of many
reasons many reasons why I hate identity
crisis they had to not only destroy one
of the few long-running stable
relationships that Universe has ever had
but they had to do it that grotesquely
when ultimately the story would barely
even be about that
I really hate identity crisis I really
do
I really do I used to think it's good
but it's too rough for me but as as the
years have gone by no I hate it I really
hate it
Melody Queen coming back in with the
Super Chat what am I most proud of
uh my novel dreams of Fire
um screw it hang on
foreign
this
this is what I'm most proud of I spent
so long
thinking about and writing and working
on this
and I'm really happy with the end result
I'm really proud of that book is it
perfect no
no piece of art is but I'm
I can look at how long that took me I
can wish that I had gotten a ton in a
more timely manner than I did but I can
look at how long that took me and look
at the end result and go
I'm I'm proud of that I didn't waste my
time
yeah I'm I'm very proud of that
jar jar Ed thank you so much for the
Super Chat yes Lori Strode was paranoid
about Michael and H2O and was
overprotective but she was able to be
well adjusted and was a teacher at a
prep school
the
I did a video focusing on this
specifically in terms of villains but we
seem to lately just in general a lot of
creators especially when they're trying
to be dark
and mature and edgy they really favor
this idea that people are defined by
trauma and defined by like a specific
trauma and
part of that is an outcropping of I
think a greater level of understanding
of much of the population of how their
Trauma from various things that they
might not have processed for a long time
does impact them as adults
and that's a good thing but like to boil
it down the way so many pieces of
entertainment boil it down is not doing
the concept Justice uh either the
reality of it nor the narrative
possibilities of it
Thomas Scott I don't know why I became a
voice but okay uh I think we'll see
Jenny the doctor's daughter back in the
60th
um
Maybe
I think it'd be weirder actually now
that they're now the not that she
intended are full-on married it would be
very weird at least for me as a viewer
for her to show up and call him dad
I don't know I feel I feel like I'm
stepping in on
um
uh somebody's private role play session
or something
so thump 10.
probably butchered that I don't know if
it's meant to be said out loud hey Vera
I feel that the Joker is too silly to be
a villain how is it possible that the
clown can cause so much havoc and give
Batman a hard time
the
I think he's a great villain now
whether or not you think he's too silly
to be a villain depends on how narrowly
you want to Define villain because a
villain is just an obstacle
he's undoubtedly an obstacle whether
he's being silly or being murderous what
the way I like The Joker Is is
unpredictable
is that day to day he could
be doing a circus-themed heist of a
corner store
for pennies
and then the next day he could try and
gas half the city to death because
that's what he finds funny that day
unfortunately way too many things have
drilled down on the Killer Clown thing
which is very tired at this point
I actually love what the Harley Quinn
Series has done with the joker I'm
surprised how much I ended up liking
that Angie I'm kind of with you on that
um Brandon King thank you very much
Seven's logo and opener are my least
fave to dated the the opening is too
dragged out and yeah that look that logo
is
so 80s
holy crap it's so 80s and I know some
people
um
some people have Nostalgia for it but
I've heard Sylvester's face was actually
painted silver for that intro I've
always listen to that Carolyn just given
the way it looks
uh all right I think oh I'm almost
caught up I'm almost caught up with the
super chats then I need to check the
Discord
um so give me a minute here John vinyls
thank you oh once again my crazy idea
for amphibia attraction is having it be
potentially have it be a potential
substitute replacement for Splash
Mountain alongside Tiana's Bayou
adventure oh
it would lend itself to
um to that sort of down uh down a
waterfall Splash kind of thing
yeah
yeah that that works okay I gotta check
the Discord I will be back in a few
minutes folks
so from the Council of Geeks it is chord
let's see uh three questions and a joke
what do you think of the news that Henry
Cavill is heading is handing the leather
the black leather over to Liam Hemsworth
for girls of Rivia and does it have
anything to do with him playing the Big
Blue Boy Scout I assume it does
um because I reported years ago that
Warner Brothers really wanted it back
and part of the reason they wanted him
back was the first season of The Witcher
had hit
um so I I would not be surprised if he
basically was put in a position where
they couldn't keep waiting for him and
he had to choose
since I don't watch The Witcher not that
I'm like not watching that just another
thing I've never gotten around to I
don't really have an opinion on its
impact on the show I would assume it's
probably a big hit recasting your lead
especially
recasting and playing the same part like
there's sometimes you can pivot to have
the lead be somebody else that usually
doesn't work but it does sometimes
Babylon 5 uh pulled it off pretty well
but having someone literally play the
same character after three seasons
yeah I don't know about that I don't
know about that
now it's nothing against Liam Hemsworth
you probably do it fine but
he's not who people want or remember
um question two James Gunn just had his
people call your people and hire you to
scream right a major DC property of your
choice which Wonder Woman story do you
write and why
see here's the thing
as much as I love Wonder Woman
I actually love her primarily as a
presence on the Justice League
as being a balancing and stabilizing
Force
more so than her own stories most of
this the individual Wonder Woman stories
that I've read I didn't like now granted
that might be part of the ones I picked
but some of the ones I've read have even
been praised like oh this is one of the
good ones I'm like really
and like I still love the character I
love Diana but
oh boy
some of the stuff that is that has her
name on it has at least most of the
stuff I've looked at has not been
great
um
I don't
trying to think if there'd be somebody
else I would immediately
gravitate towards I mean Harley Quinn's
been being done to death and
unfortunately poison ivy a little bit
um by extension
um because of because of them being so
much tied together now
I don't know
I bring back Ambush Bug
just to throw everybody off
ah should DC Studios try and rebuild
their TV brand on free TV like the CW or
should they go
um streaming like Disney plus does why
or why not
um
uh honestly right now I don't think they
should really be trying to do either
they're probably better off in a holder
in a holding pattern with most of the
arrowverse stuff
um already closed out or closing out
soon the CW doesn't have great
penetration normally I'd say focus it on
the streaming but HBO Max is going to
get folded into Discovery plus and who
knows what the hell that's going to look
like or whether it's going to be worth
the money so right now honestly I think
they need to put the TV stuff on hold
until that stuff Settles
joke how many uh fam Trad witches does
it take to screw in a light bulb none if
candles were good enough for Grandma
they're good enough for me
if you um if you yourself are not a
witch or don't
um dwell in witching communities you
might not get that uh or at least all
the terminology involved
I liked it
any advice you have for someone who is
possibly moving to a Northern State
North Midwest to be exact
long underwear
you may not think of it immediately you
will regret not having it come February
and that's what we're going to go
through and that was it for questions
that came in before the start of the
stream I know there was more one more
that came in I might answer that
directly on the Discord but
the rule is that questions need to be
before the stream starts so
I'm now back there are more Super chats
hey
uh jar jar Ed
almost caught up the Joker Laugh
intensifies oh okay we're doing that
[Laughter]
you're welcome
uh 255 A.D thank you very much for the
Super Chat it seems like labor will take
power Nest uh in the next UK election if
given the hard Choice should we left us
want economically right Centrist parties
in power so long as they're okay on
social issues ah
if your options are
um
if your options are between
um
vaguely Progressive on social and
economically right versus right on
everything yes that is better if you
have a viable left option I cannot
stress enough that it it really should
be taken
98 of the time
because the the far right continues to
pull all of the right further in its
direction and pulling as hard as
possible the other way I do think
is the main thing that needs to happen
in democracies but
uh
I don't know I don't know enough about
the UK specifics jar jar Ed once more
Capital says he would stay for all
playing seven seasons of The Witcher if
they were true to the source material
days ago a former writer said half the
team hate the books and the games can't
help but wins oh
oh
how'd they end up on that gig then well
I mean I guess if it's work for hire you
know you write what you get assigned but
yeah that's a little
huh
There's an actual proper Christmas Story
sequel with some of the original cast
coming to HBO Max soon why
why
well I know why
Nostalgia and brand recognition that's
that's why do I wear curlers no I do not
this is just what my hair does good
handle left well done yes thank you Dad
joke Cinema that was indeed very much a
Hamill Joker Laugh specifically can I do
the Chucky laugh I don't know it well
enough uh Child's Play and the Chucky
franchise is another one that I've only
seen
uh one and a half of the movies I've
seen all of Bride of Chucky and most of
Seed of Chucky but that was a long time
ago
uh his is more of a cackle isn't it sort
of the yeah
kind of thing that's not quite it though
I don't
um
I I don't I don't know the franchise
well enough
255 A.D thank you once again for the
Super Chat how'd the Paradox costume
turn out for the kiddo
oh wow okay so I kind of alluded to just
in general
um my kids Halloween costume being
a lot
but um
so if you're familiar with Steven
Universe my kiddos costume
was peridot
it was made by her mother
it was
basically screen accurate
the leotard the the bright shades of
green the the sort of diamond the yellow
diamonds on the knees custom made the
like these kind of water shoes in the
right colors
um like body paint here up her face the
right color green made a visor her
mother made
the hair the big yellow triangle hair
she made this
helmet of a massive wig
it was it was really good the kiddo
rocked it it's one of the few times that
I
am annoyed at my choice to not share my
kiddos image publicly I'm still not
going to
but like
it was real good it was it was real good
have I seen the Chucky TV show on sci-fi
I have not I don't have sci-fi like your
earrings thank you I think you've
mentioned that before with these ones Ms
Wicked Wolf
uh do you have any worries about how
they're going to handle Yasmin Finney on
Doctor Who trans representation on the
BBC is usually quite bad
um the thing is I don't think I've seen
much in the way of trans representation
in the drama Department I know BBC News
is
absolutely terrible
with anything related to trans issues
but
I have not seen a trans representation
that's come out of the drama Department
of the BBC so I don't know if it's as
bad over there and I also have a decent
amount of faith in Russell T Davis so
there we go
ah
I think we're about to um
we're about to wrap it up
no disrespect but Fiona duraf's laugh is
way better I love that franchise so much
I I like that she's become a big part of
that you know that's become a become a
family thing
can you maybe just post the wig that's
the part I'm really curious about I uh
I'll have to go through my camera roll
to see if I can find a picture of just
the wig and maybe maybe no promises but
maybe
um because I can't remember if I took a
picture of the wig by itself or not
but uh
in any case
always wrapping always wrap it up before
drilling down
and that's that my friends
because why that man is a professional
for those who don't know John Van Luling
who's in the chat
we have historically hosted um burlesque
shows together
um and then that kind of line was very
typical of the kind of Rapport we would
have
and also we had a podcast for a little
bit called go home Hollywood you're
drunk which was a lot of fun but then
um
uh he had a kid I already had a kid but
he had a kid and we took what was
supposed to be initially a Hiatus and
then just the logistics didn't work out
and in the time since then I've filled
my schedule
uh with other stuff and
it's a shame because that was a lot of
fun but uh oh love you JBL you know that
uh jar jar Ed thank you very much one
more Super Chat a summary of how fans
reacted to Cavill leaving The Witcher
well the only person that cares about
The Witcher is gone now ooh
yeah if that's the perception that he is
like the only major fan of the original
property in who was in any kind of
creative input position yeah that's uh
that's a bad that's a bad sign
but anyways
um I'm gonna wrap it up
um I just got a proper buzz cut today
intended to go into 2023 with full NB
stud energy yeah do it Rowan do it proud
of you
all right everybody thank you so much
for joining me
kicking off a new month and I hope that
I hope that you enjoyed this I hope that
you have a good rest of your week I hope
you have a good November
well with midterms I hope we all have a
good November as Lisa good as one as
can be had under the circumstances but
in any case
I want you to remember that you are
beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
oh thank you Carolyn I gotta hype stuff
that's coming out is the thing I down to
the rest of my totally not spiked cider
and uh and forgot thank you Carolyn
tomorrow
tomorrow on the main Channel there is
kind of my final overview thoughts on
Channel's era as a whole on Doctor Who
Saturday is my new revised ranking of
the doctors my favorite portrayals
ranked from worst to best now with new
entries in there because I have resisted
doing it during Whitaker's run so that
is on Saturday uh also tomorrow
streaming on Twitch I'm still playing
inscription I want to try and finish
that one out
uh I think
I think that's about it for right now
thank you for the reminder Carolyn that
was badly needed
Eternal sailor Hufflepuff sneaking in at
the last minute how did you do peridot's
gemstone for your kids costume Oh you
mean the one on her head literally
literally just just stuck a bit of
shininess in the right shape to her head
with spirit gum
oh anyway there we go I think I got it
now I think I got it thank you Carolyn
thank you Karen I I like I don't know
how I would manage this without you I
really don't so anyways thank you all so
very much be well be safe and be kind
mccavity